oh dude alcohol and benad come on dog
what are you crazy that's harsh for your
liver what are you nuts that's when you
[Music]
do check this out
everybody got nothing but media today
Yeah Baby W what is
that wa that's that's a Kool-Aid Factory
is broken holy can you imagine drinking
that look
at wait is that that guy Mexican are
they speaking Spanish no they're
speaking Portuguese oh if it was Mexican
it was a hamaica
factory but they're speaking in
Portuguese therefore it is a it's Inca
Cola oh no that's green I mean wine it's
red wine wow oh wait it it is it's red
wine so this whole town in Port has been
flooded by 600,000 gallons of red wine
because at The Distillery two tanks
bursted I thought this was jokes dog I
thought that was just a flood no that's
red wine imagine [__] 600,000 gallon
why is nobody
going or this maybe we just didn't catch
them on camera yeah there has to be
somebody doing that or maybe they're
also like I wonder how many [__]
miles of Road this just went down before
I go sip sip sip but it's the top layer
that's the safe layer agre but wouldn't
it be kind of Burn aians by swimming in
there because you'll just be like oh my
God and then you're just like
alcohol yes open wounds oh yeah yeah if
you have mosquito bik so two tanks owned
by lava Distillery were responsible for
the Deluge and uh this video shows uh
the wine going down through a population
town of 2,000 people um The Wine Company
def definitely said that they will pay
for all damages and stuff like that you
know what I mean um nobody was injured
or anything but yeah imagine owning a
Distillery having two of your tanks
burst so 600,000 600,000 y well how many
tanks do they own like three that would
be a bummer we got two of them burst
imagine you just lost so much half a
m that's your whole livelihood whatever
more local media reported that spillage
triggered a local environmental alert as
the fire department made efforts to
divert the wine to prevent the
contamination of the nearby River fire
department is in charge of that [__] too
they they got to divert it from going to
the river I thought they were just like
how they going do that I put out fires
yeah how do you yeah what about the
water department yeah is that that's
their job they're fired we do fire you
do water dude especially in a small town
like that you said 2,000 people there's
logic to that yeah dude you're [__]
up your whole town I think this should
have been the Earth Department yep and
then the the air Department Boy Scouts
and the sanitation and then the water
department they should have got together
and been like we all need to work
together the fire department like there
was not one flame we have nothing to do
with it this is the opposite of what we
do our construction dang imagine if it
wasn't wine and it was just like other
alcohol that could be flammable I was
thinking this same thing cuz it's wine
like FL a river of fire that would be
holy [__] like Fireball 5150 or like the
high alcohol content Stu Fireball
actually on fire you said f pompe oh
pompe that would be crazy if it was
flammable and just one thing
just but they don't they don't keep
alcohol like that right they don't have
[__] tanks tanks of alcohol yeah like
whisky and barrels Tequilas and barrels
it's small batch right that's what
they're proud of yeah you would have to
[__] somebody would have to come in
and just chop every barrel at the same
time for so they make wine in giant
[__] tanks that's why yeah I guess so
is that box wine that has to be box wine
yeah probably box wine huh $12 wine sack
of
joas you ever play that game no in
college you just throw a sack of of yeah
so you know college you buy like [__]
really cheap ass wine at the store and
then uh during parties people would just
take that bag of wine and they would
throw it at you and yell sack of joina
if you didn't catch it you'd have to
just like down a bunch and then you very
dumb a guaranteed hangover the next day
yeah guaranteed hang every single time
oh it's like Mike Ike why the [__] is
Mike Ike why not in college off oh yeah
yeah you know what I'm talking the red
bottle if you accidentally open it or
touch it you have to pound it it's very
dumb
stuff but very fun
stuff I had this one dessert wine it was
so delicious but I had the craziest
headache after yeah really story my life
Stella Roosa no it was like candy I was
like Wow Stella Rosa tastes like candy
yeah anybody here like wine I know you
two
don't every once in a while with dinner
but very rarely but people swear by when
they eat steak red wine is good or like
pasta with white wine and I'm like it
tastes when you get wine with uh steak
or wine with like cheese even oh Che
okay I get that it's like I see why
these things I've never tried it I
should try it fits very well and it's
very light it's like almost like juice
has a weird aftertaste well if it's it's
also an acquired taste like beer the
first time is also [__] weird right
bro alcohol just [__] me up dog me too
I get sick Bro I I turn red I get like
the room spins I get headaches hey
that's why we probably all have the more
he's saying the more it makes me want to
drink right now yeah yeah I get crazy I
black out did you know it was like it
was like 40% of genetics in Asian can't
um process it efficiently that's why you
get Asian glow bro I get bro I turned
purple me too dude it like it looks
sickening it looks like I'm sick I wish
I could enjoy it
I drink whiskey at the same time I'm
kind of glad because it is one of the
most expensive beverages you could drink
and it's probably the mo like the least
well there's just no benefit to drinking
alcohol it's like there's just no
benefit at all yeah but good times good
times besides Good Times time I want to
feel good yeah you are but you pay for
it I feel like you always pay for it the
next couple I feel like you pay for the
alcohol yeah there's so many things that
can make you feel good from like eating
to play or whatever but then I'm missing
out on something that I can drink and
with my meal what about theu feels good
theu is [__] good dude I won't drink
alcohol but I'll drink some lean theu
[__] me up drink some Pro meth hey
lowkey though sometimes I be like really
happy I have to take nightquil yeah I'm
like I'm going to sleep good toight cuz
I'll go like this it puts it in the cup
I'm like I don't need no
cup you guys you guys are night cool
people I'm more of a benad dril guy I'm
a benad dril guy benad good
stuff I got benad in my bag that's what
I'm saying dude you just take a little
sip just a little bit you don't go crazy
and it knocks you the [__] out and
you're just like get you get you try to
stay up and that's the fun part you try
to stay up yeah and then you eventually
go sleep I tried it one time and that
was I was like I'm not doing it anymore
I take the P The Power of Will D you
know yeah I have the pills pills the
pills exhilarating yeah yeah it's a good
time it's a good Thursday night usually
I don't drink I don't know [__] about
wine you know red [__] white [__]
this blah blah I just know that if it's
free on the airp airplane I'm going to
drink it cuz I want to sleep fun right
but sleep fun that's a good see I'm
missing out on this alcohol thing man
but recently I had a couple experiences
cuz I would when I'm with other people
that want to drink wine but I bought you
guys this prence I'm going to have some
right now it's not my first preference
okay don't black out or black out
actually that's kind of funny but when
you have a wine Dr drunk it's actually
really fun it's a different cuz you know
different alcohols produce different
types of drums like it makes you like
talk more be more social or something
well I understand why like all the you
know the ladies just love drinking wine
and just like talking [__] and going
crazy I just I there's something about
it then I'm like oh how what she's
having my lady goes crazy anytime they
go we have sangria she's like oh you
guys have sangria let's get let's get
sangria everybody wants to get sangria
and [__] just cuz they put some [__]
dice peaches in there yeah but there's
something about it right suddenly they
turn up and they're like they're
everything's funny and you're like okay
I'll have one I'm like babe did you
bring the benad come on that's what I'm
asking for oh dude alcohol and benad
come on dog what are you crazy that's
harsh for your liver what are you nuts
that's when you [__]
[Laughter]
do stupid pretty good that was pretty
good yeah do it every now I like mold
wine that shit's delicious one is that
like the Christmas one yeah with the
berries and the so it's actual wine huh
yeah what about all the other Asian
wines like sake so oh I like sake all
day you like sake sake is even if it's
warm too the warm sake is similar to
like wine in a sense where it's like you
can just drink it and it doesn't feel
like alcohol oh it feels like it to me
yep do you get the same effects start
burning up I'm going have fun for about
20 minutes and then I get [__] you get
wrecked huh yeah it's just like a oh I'm
a
I'm I'm kind of glad I don't drink
alcohol just because I know like I
probably wouldn't be able to handle it
dude dude Whiskey on the Rock I do when
I see you guys drinking in here and you
guys have like a a drink and you guys go
in the back and you guys have your fun
no drinks yeah that's I feel like I want
to sip on this do you guys feel left out
for sure well cuz here's the
thing no we all need our jollies right
so like you guys oh drink oh I feel good
I have to get my nipples tickled yeah so
it's like completely different y it's
it's a it's not socially definitely
completely different Joe I'm glad that
you know that yeah that's crazy I have
to be a lame ass and grab like a energy
drink or something to feel like ca yeah
but it's not the same it's not the
[__] same I like being on a caffeine
high with caffeine people cuz we're
talking at 1,000 milph and we're on the
same wavel yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
when you're around alcoholics and you're
on a caffeine high get the [__] out of
my face
slurring [__] I will only drink
with certain people like oh they're all
annoying I will only drink with certain
people I don't like when people get
really touchy when they're drunk and
they start like hey let me tell you
something dude and they do that [__]
you're like oh this is cuz they want to
feel connected and then they'll talk to
you like this far apart be like he you
know you're like my [__] best friend
you know that and then they're all like
oh shut the [__] up you stetin and then
you move back and then they follow you
and you move yeah I'm suddenly feeling
attacked I feel attacked you guys don't
do that though I feel confident I'm
usually like
yeah [__] in a vehicle I like to go
out my motorcycle I just get crazy did
you drive your motorcycle here today no
I don't no I didn't you like chucking
some beers and jumping on the motorcycle
you shotgun no whiskey it real quick
boom Whiskey on the Rock that's what I
always this the two-handed you see that
boom oh you're not drinking your [__]
okay boom and then having a good time
the music feels better too sometimes
you're like ooh a lot of things do feel
good on stimulants
now I'm not feeling attack everyone's
happy everyone's like yo the this is
happening all the time you
talk constant handshakes you know what
I'm saying for real
yeah it's it's a good vibe yeah yeah now
I'm missing out I think let's just all
do
mushrooms it's the next JK
[Music]
Adventure